geometry measurement diagrams are not
scaled not to scale let's have a look in
the diagram up x equals so you had to
find this angle you had to know that the
eggless of a triangle was angles of a
triangle 180 degrees there so notified X
you take away the other two angles that
right angle there is 90 degrees you got
your 25 degrees there so that's why you
subtract you end up with 65 question 2
same idea almost exactly the same except
it's not the anguish on the triangle
it's the egg with some of a revolution
which is 360 all the way around right so
that's where you've got this 360 here
you take away your other two angles and
you end up with 209 going down here to
question 3 you've got your parallel
lines here ok so you might have done a
bit of working on the page you might
have noticed that X and this egg whap
here they're the same so you can call
that X degrees why is that why are these
two angles are saved
what kind of was are they there we got
three we've got three kinds of angles on
parallel lines your corresponding your
Co interior and you've got alternate
okay now what are the shapes that
correspond to each one corresponding to
the F Co interior is the C and what
shape what letter did you get from the
alternating book it's the set or an a
depending on which way you draw it okay
so if I look at these two that looks to
be most like it's a death it's just kind
of slanted over can you see that so
that's why they're corresponding angles
that's X and that's X the angle sum of
this line here is 180 degrees so that's
why the work here is 180 minus 135 okay
it's not the only way I'll turn it for
that you might have said that X is here
as well because one of these two angles
they are vertically opposite so they're
equal and then you go interior angles
here same thing 180 minus 135 in the
diagram above ah this is what we looked
at before Co interior angles
so that's why you've got 180 minus 23
because Co interior egg was out what's
the words that to this this
supplementary which means they add up to
180
X plus 43 equals 180 and you can see
when they take 43 from both sides that's
what gives you this line okay over the
page the perimeter of this figure so
prove it oh you have to add everything
up they do give you all of the sides
every single one okay so you can't add
all of them up and you'll get 26 I'll
give you a bit of a of a sneaky clue by
the way look at this shape so we're
looking shape right but do you agree
that if I change the shape a little bit
for example if I compare it to this see
that 3 meter I'm gonna put it over there
and this 4 meter I'm gonna put it over
there so now what I've got is a
rectangle all the way around do you
agree that the rectangle that I've just
drawn and the original shape they have
the same perimeter can you see that I
just I've just moved those sides to
different places or rectangles their
previous really easy that's 6 and that's
7 the perimeter of a rectangle you just
have to double both of those that's 13
you're double have you get 26 same thing
okay
so sometimes when they don't give you
lengths you can take advantage of the
fact that a shape like this you can
compare it to a shape that you do know
rectangles are easy the area of this
figure is it's made up of two figures so
we have a name for this that's in the C
do you remember when it's made up of two
shapes we call it a composite shape
we've shoved it together a rectangle and
a triangle okay so you can see they've
got the rectangle here six times five
and they have the triangle here this is
a next time
breath and this is base 1/2 base times
height so you've got the 4 there and
that's 6 across there because it's
opposite that side ok so that's where
you get those calculations 12 plus 13
gives you the 42
the circumference of a circle is given
by this formula that's nice that they
handed it to you calculate the
circumference of this circle to the
nearest centimeter so all you have to do
is take that formula and you had to
stick it R equals 5 so you can see that
okay it was just one mark you could just
do it on your calculator and they want
it to the nearest centimeter so that
point 4 rounds down that's why you get
31 the area of these triangles 84
centimeters squared what's the height so
here is V tricky before you had height
and base and then you working out area
but here they give you area and base and
they want you to work out height so it's
a slightly different theme you start by
writing out the area formula like so and
then you fit all the numbers in where
they belong and that gives you your
final answer